at this stage of your career how do you
measure your own success
how do i measure my own success i have
to admit we just talked about social
media
um that what is fun is that you have a
direct feedback loop
from your audience audience on twitter
so i do
read twitter um and their comments
because the great thing is that that
people that are posting on twitter
don't think that you're reading it so
it's really
it's the purest feedback you can get
more
than i get from my family or from my
agents or from anyone
ever the most honest opinion is twitter
and what is great about it too which you
always
forget it's kind of the innocence and
the the lack of cynicism
with which a general audience outside of
hollywood consumes your stuff because
you are in in this bubble of
other storytellers and filmmakers and
and you spend your life on that and you
develop your stuff in that and they test
view it you're always in this mindset of
what is
new what is cutting edge what is
unpredictable
pop up all that stuff and then you put
it out there and you realize
that the the scene that you thought was
the most generic and you were slightly
embarrassed by
people get so excited about and we
did an episode of fear the walking dead
and there was someone's head getting
chopped off some zombies head getting
chopped off
and that is suddenly the most exciting
moment for everybody and
it it reminds me of this pure joy of
of consuming cinema that i i think i
threw out the window and sacrificed when
i went to film school
because that was taken from me the
actual watching a movie as a movie and
enjoying it as a movie and not always
thinking am i cool and intellectual
in liking this or not like because your
either liked something or you didn't
like something
so that's always a real interesting
thing to kind of
get that reaction so a lot of how i
judge my success
is how thrilled or enthusiastic
are people on twitter as individuals i
don't even know if there are 10 people
of them out there or
a thousand people it almost doesn't
matter because it's
it's it goes back to why you originally
wanted to tell stories to evoke
a genuine emotion in someone if it's
just that one person
that says my favorite movie is and then
it's my movie
which seems to happen with i did that as
a test to just type in some random indie
movie
that i didn't make to just see if it's
somebody's favorite movie
and it is you almost can't put a movie
title into twitter that someone has not
said it's their new favorite movie
and that's the most beautiful thing in
the world to think that i not because
i'm special or a great filmmaker but
just by the virtue of having made
a movie i created someone's favorite
movie
that's almost enough of a success to to
justify
wanting to make movies all over again do
you respond
you said you do respond no oh you don't
okay no
i've done that in the in the at the very
beginning because i thought oh how cool
would it have been when i was young
um that the filmmaker actually responds
yeah that would have blown my mind so i
did that in the beginning
but it never ends well because you can't
live live up to that because
which i totally understand that for an
audience it's hard
to have that contact and then not have
that contact
anymore so then you're getting chris in
that case chris i'm still getting
christmas emails from
someone i was in touch with 2010 and the
first years i still wrote back but then
how do you
you know so the especially with negative
stuff like never
it's always a mistake to respond in any
way to negative stuff
because you can't you can't win
you know other than you can
maybe you could if you wanted to respond
you could respond positively
and say good point i see your criticism
um but to defend yourself is always a
mistake
and we were in film school we were
prepped really well for that because we
made our
short films and then we presented them
to the class and we had to sit
in front of the screen and kind of look
at the look at your class and you
weren't
allowed to respond they would throw all
their criticism at you
and your only exercise was to say
thank you for the for the criticism not
justify anything not say anything
that was the greatest prep in the world
because
in real life you also don't get to i
mean on twitter you might if you wanted
to you could reply to two or three
people
but there are tens of thousands of other
people whom you don't get to respond
to like your thing that you made and put
out there
and ask them to donate two years of to
do
hours of their lifetime too has to speak
for itself you don't get any directors
commentary
on that stuff or any you know q a
afterwards where you get to justify
stuff
so you better make sure that you say
everything that you needed to say
in the main piece that's why again why
test screenings to me
among friends or among a small group of
people are so important because there
you still
get to react but once you shoot it out
into the world
that's it you're done and it's really
hard it's really hard to
have people for example misunderstand
stuff and say stuff about your movie
where you're like you misunderstand the
entire and some of them love the movie
but understand it completely wrong and
you want to say like no that's not at
all but you don't get to that's that's
kind of their privilege
to you had the privilege that they
listened to you for two hours
and now it's their prevalent privilege
that for the rest of your life they're
allowed to say whatever they want about
your movie and you have to take it
whether you listen to it or not is a
different thing but you don't get to
reply
that seems fair to me in the end is that
common
to have a class in film school where
you're sort of
allowed to be like the peanut gallery so
to speak is allowed to kind of throw
food at you a little bit at the film
school i went to
it was that's very progressive from the
very yeah yeah maybe
maybe this is in germany no it was here
here oh
yeah um and it was good that we weren't
allowed i remember that one
in the in the beginning maybe there were
classes where we were still allowed to
answer
and one of my fellow directors sweetest
guy super talented
said the film that ended the sentence
that ended his film school career
um and he said to someone saying
something oh that's what i was going for
that's what i was
wanting to do but i didn't think that my
cinematographer
and my editor were capable of it
and you just could feel the silence and
for the next two and a half years nobody
wanted to
to work with them and i know that's not
how he meant right he meant it in terms
of
that it could be done in the time frame
that the school gives sure
with the equipment that this but there
he didn't get a second shot at it he was
like
he had the from then on out the were the
least talented cinematographers the ones
that no one else wanted to team up with
it echoed through so i was always kind
of glad that the mandate for the other
lesson was you don't get to respond
because then you can put can't put your
foot in your mouth at least
you